bonjour ici c'est steve kaufmann je veux
parler aujourd'hui de de l'apprentissage
des langues
ce que moi je trouve intéressant valable
ceux qui meurent mathy envers l'étude
des langues et il opposait deux soirs
c'est à dire la peau les mises à sion la
démagogie la politisation de la question
linguistique et de mon avis les vidéos
que j'ai vue de claude hagège à youtube
semble indiquer qu'il est plutôt
intéressés ce dernier aspect bilan
c'est-à-dire son aspect politique
j'avais dix sages avaient critiqué
claude hagège dans un vidéo récents ou
pas tellement récent mais au préalable
qu'ils avaient fait à youtube
les défenseurs de la langue française
sont venus me critiquer dire que j'étais
dix ans que je je je
c'était en faveur de la propagation de
l'anglais de l'hégémonie anglaise et
cetera et cetera
bon je veux expliquer un peu mon point
de vue j'ai devant moi le livre que qui
a écrit claude hagège il ya 15 ans qui
s'appelle le français et l'histoire d'un
combat qui a d'ailleurs été a servi de
base à l'est à une émission de
télévision
et ce livre prend donc la langue comme
une c'est une expression pour lui de mon
avis si je lis ce livre c'est une
expression de la grandeur de la france
il en dit il il identifie avec avec le
pays avec dans le rayonnement culturel
il est tout content d'expliquer comment
les les
normand qui parlaient français on peut
imposer leur langue aux anglais et que
les mots les plus sophistiqués sont
restés français d'inspiration française
dans la langue anglaise
alors que les mots de tous les jours
sont plutôt d'origine anglo saxonne mais
ensuite il se trouve que il ya un déclin
du français hors de france qui n'est pas
limitée à la en angleterre donc il écrit
le prestige du français l'avait fait
rayonner dans les cours et les familles
nobles à travers l'europe de l'espagne
la suède à batna il en est tout fier
alors l'expansion du français au moyen
âge c'est très bon que ça a été fait à
par la force des armes par les normands
qui sont allés conquérir la sissili la
sicile époque en france et oui pas
cécile c'est bon parce que c'est le
rayonnement c'est l'expansion du
français
ça c'est bien et il dit par exemple en
chapitre iii se replie sur la france ne
peut empêcher qu'il retire de son
brillant passé un assez grand prestige
alors tout cela est bon c'est bon bon
il continue dans le livre voilà il
raconte donc le résistance la résistance
les résistances du latin aux français et
aux autres la langue vulgaire mais
surtout comme la lingue langue
internationale le français commencent à
remplacer le latin et cela est dû un
large mesure au fait que la française
devient le pays le plus puissant sur le
continent européen
avec des victoires militaires etc et on
voit que des tracts et de plus en plus
sont rédigées en français le français
devient la langue diplomatique
c'est tout à fait à l'honneur du
français et ça a fait augmenter le
le prestige du français il est moins
disons monsieur hagège
ils règlent regrette au moins là la
suppression des langues régionales
au moins quand il a écrit ce livre il ya
quinze ans parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai vu
des vidéos il
il semble être plus en faveur de la de
ressusciter donc les langues les langues
régionales en france et ensuite il est
il se plaint de 2 du fait que après la
la première guerre mondiale où le traité
de versailles va traiter vers ça a été a
été avec deux versions officielles
une anglaise et l'autre française
et bah il cite linguiste à may et qui
écrit pour une innovation singulière et
absurde
le traité de versailles a été rédigée en
deux langues le français et l'anglais
les deux textes faisant également foi la
bla bla la fin d'une guerre où la france
a joué le premier rôle militaire a donc
consacré la ruine du privilège qui
faisait du français lui ni plan
diplomatique
c'est à dire pour lui quand le français
est une langue dominante ce soit dans le
domaine diplomatique ou dans les
colonies c'est très bon mais quand
l'anglais à cause d'eux aussi des
facteurs historiques et comme
l'importance ico économique et politique
des états unis où a même avancé de
l'angleterre
eh ben ça c'est très mauvais mais pour
moi tout ça c'est du tout ça enfin et
parce que l'anglais que nous connaître
connaissons aujourd'hui c'est une langue
qui a évolué à partir dans une influence
français et autres on peut penser que si
les normands n'avait pas envahi
l'angleterre il ya mille ans si c'était
les scandinaves
lorsqu'il était présent sur les îles
britanniques
ba soit la langue parlée en angleterre
serait une langue germanique comme le
l'anglo-saxon soir sacs sont mélangés
avec la langue les langues scandinaves
avec un apport à la teuf
tout ça c'est des évolutions naturelles
qu'il y ait des mots en français qui
sont d'origine anglaise ou russes
cambistes bistrot c'est parce que ces
mots là servent les gens les trouvent
utile et les utilisent je ne vois pas de
dommage à cela et quand il dit par
exemple un bord dans ce livre il dit
faye pour lui la l'influencé américaine
ou anglaise
ces sinistres il cite l'exemple des ja
le body scan sur les pieds avait enfin
d'autres organisations jetez pas vos
remarques etc qui font de la propagation
de l'anglais afin que c'était une espèce
de complot colonialiste veille aussi
l'alliance française mais elle la
société dante et le goethe institut
mais il n'y a rien de mauvais dans tout
cela et tous ces organisations la
utilise des fonds publics qui est où est
le problème
donc tous les propos de monsieur hagège
je trouve très très acerbe il était ma
gang qu'il utilise des mots
inflammatoires pour se battre contre une
chance qui ne peut pas empêcher c'est à
dire les gens vont parler comme ils
volent parce que la langue française
d'aujourd'hui
ça n'a pas été ça n'existe pas de vide
et d'été des millénaires un des mines et
des milliers d'années de données c'est
une langue qui a évolué avec l'
influence du latin enfin à base du la
base il atteint avec d'autres influences
et ses 7 c'est une langue qui a un bilan
sera différent de la langue qui est
parlée aujourd'hui
donc de mon avis il est beaucoup mieux
de se concentrer sur l'apprentissage des
langues comme il est parlé par la
plupart des gens donc usage normal qui
est qui qui prédomine dans
quel que soit le pays et quelle que soit
la langue donc en écoutant en lisant les
journaux la télévision les gens qu'on
rencontre et en essayant de limiter la
façon de parler de ces gens là c'est ce
que je fais quand je reprends des landes
je vais pas me poser des questions quand
j'apprends le russe si ce mot là est
d'origine grecque anglais allemands
suédois latin parce qu'il ya de tout
cela et français aussi dans le russe
mais c'est la langue pour moi c'est un
mot russe également japonais ou à
n'importe quel nom donc j'aime je n'aime
pas la politique aux politiciens
politisation des langues
j'aime les enfants et jeunes élèves
j'aime les apprendre d'une façon
naturelle et sans trop de deux
d'amertume
comme on voit chez les messieurs hagège
il peut presque parce se contrôler quand
il quand ils discutent de le soi-disant
hégémonie de l'anglais peut-être qu'on
aura une hégémonie du chinois dans
quelques années ou 1 1
moi j'aimerais bien avoir un re
lancement des langues latines
mais la roma promène mais c'est plutôt
l'espagnol qui est parlé par la plus
grand nombre de personnes qui seraient
donc le la porte drapeau survenue des
langues d'origine latine qui pourrait
faire face à cette influence de
l'anglais ceci dit j'aime je suis contre
l'idée que chaque conférence
internationale doit forcément se
dérouler en anglais
j'essaie avec notre site à l'idée de
faciliter l'apprentissage d'autres
langues
mais ces pratiques lendemain c'est sale
c'est ça qui est un inconvénient ou coco
common ck oui j'aimerais bien que tout
le monde puisse parler beaucoup de
langues
j'aime bien ça ça nous apporte beaucoup
de choses mais finalement c'est aussi
très commun d'avoir une lande en commun
et
je ne joue pas je ne vois pas la
possibilité pour l'espéranto ou autre
langue artificielle a supplanté
l'anglais à court terme à moyen terme
donc le relais et common est utile mais
oui absolument apprenez d'autres langues
ça vous donne accès à d'autres cultures
d'autres films d'autres livres d'une
autre façon par les pensées et ses bas
là c'est ce que j'avais à dire merci
voir